what have you done to my wall this is so
weird you paint over cracks I know this
here I know and this apparently is
something new that it's falling apart
Wow I mean must be one way it's sucking
where the plasters just wow he's a bits
of card that's correct
it was a temporary fix says no mural
this business cars you put your cards on
here and then you paint over the cards
you should make a label for this
decaying wall do not paint over it I
mean the walls rotten and you just go
and paint over it it was members of
temporary wall is Rossum you're right
and you just paint over it you can't
just go filling cracks with tacky
painting looking down him you've gone
over cracks and holes look what's that
in there I put some sort of a mesh
because it was hole and I didn't want
any
Jesus I wish you wouldn't use that word
what hole would you rethink [ __ ]
hallelujah that'd be better
can you get me Karen I can get any care
please Jesus
watch your language sir
[Music]
miss Karen oh my before the whole thing
just started coming off the wall needs
repairing and she's just painting over
it and the secondly she found a big hole
here started putting her cards on there
and then painted over that but inside
the hole oh jesus this is not a paper
mache what's she doing to your hotel
it didn't go outside me it's not a hole
to the outside there's no handouts or no
just me
the stone wall is out there I was
sleeping on the inside we're not
sleeping on the outside right so you're
not gonna get any cold drafts or
anything through there it's just like I
don't get to use the Wardrobe and the
holes on the inside not on the outside
and we can just do whatever we want it's
just stuffing
it's very silent many stars right
we can't just paint over that you can do
my dad back and then stick brillo pads
in the hole
you can't just burn down this place gosh
just wash my hands in order french bread
as an app all right is that the sports
bar or these TV screens one of those
microwaves
how many microwaves if he goes for here
and one in there at five there's one in
there I'm two chefs two chefs oh my god
what turn that's just junk everywhere
well this is cooking stuff just not
about cooking something no that's okay
how does this kitchen function give me a
little tour it's very challenging very
very challenging well sign them
that's a burger get on heating up boys
yeah you're boiling a burger I'm just
heating it back up we say he's me back
up why are you cooking it from fresh we
make them another time this is what we
got here we don't a bold burger are you
where the burgers of boils ah
no do you think your customer will want
a burger boiled in water they seem to
like them